good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-6819
object class
ketter uncontained
special containment procedures
research into the causes and effects of
scp-6819
and possible preventative measures are
ongoing currently foundation protocol
discourages travel from the hours of 11
pm to 4 am unless absolutely necessary
in which case a party of four or more is
strongly encouraged if an
scp-6819 event is triggered the driver
should maintain a fast but safe speed
and not attempt a u-turn or to otherwise
change direction after the building is
cited confirming presence in scp-6819-1
drivers should switch lanes or otherwise
maneuver around any obstructions in the
road in the event of humanoid presence
in the road personnel are authorized to
accelerate to a ramming speed
under absolutely no circumstances are
personnel to ever stop
exit the vehicle or approach the
building
description
scp-6819
is a phenomenon occurring on highways in
the united states numbered highway
system in the contiguous united states
scp-6819 involves the sudden
translocation of a vehicle driving on a
u.s highway to scp-6819-1
an extra-dimensional region of unclear
bounds and its subsequent return
scp-6819-1
resembles a u.s highway with all
identifying signage removed and no
natural illumination the surrounding
area is difficult to see and variable
but the area to the right will always be
a gently sloping rocky hill at the top
of the hill an unclear distance away a
large building is present the exact
physical characteristics of this
building change but all subjects report
it as imposing or intimidating with high
walls illuminated by floodlights
descriptions range from a prison to a
castle to a military base and similar
facilities
the requirements for triggering scp-6819
are unclear but a few prerequisites have
been ascertained
the driver of the vehicle must be
currently or formally employed by the
foundation the vehicle must be moving
independently not towed or transported
on a truck bed the time must be between
11 pm and 4 am local time zone the moon
must be in a waning period there must be
no more than 3 passengers inside the
vehicle including the driver
scp-6819-1
always contains an event forcing or
incentivizing the driver to slow down or
stop and exit the vehicle the specifics
of the event are never consistent
instance 56
circumstances 2009 chevrolet tahoe
foundation issue driver was agent mila
barrow no passengers
us-46 in missouri
observations
scp-6819 triggered at 12 17 am local
time agent barrow reports she noticed
the sudden absence of other vehicles but
did not consider it a point of concern
and continued driving a few minutes
later she realized her dashboard clock
had stopped displaying and her phone was
no longer in service and grew concerned
at the continued lack of human presence
at this point the building it must have
been miles away on that hill i could
barely make it out through the tree line
became visible agent barrow continued
driving but prepared her service weapon
i'm not sure why i was locked in a car
with bulletproof windows and there
wasn't anything overtly dangerous around
several minutes later the right lane was
obstructed by the corpse of a large elk
or moose being faced upon by a
significantly larger animal possibly a
bear the bear's fur was extremely dark
to the point of absorbing light around
it and had morphological alterations
its arms were distinctly thin and long
compared to the rest of it like human
arms the prey was still alive despite
the surrounding asphalt being coated
with its blood and continued to thrash
and emit guttural screams as barrow
changed lanes and accelerated past it in
her rearview mirror she reported the
predator sitting on its hind legs and
staring at her vehicle with glassy white
eyes barrows exited back into local
reality at 12 38 am and immediately
reported the incident
instance 165
circumstances 2004 toyota sienna driver
was dr adam makowitz with his wife dana
mackowitz in the passenger seat us-82 in
new mexico
observations
scp-6819 triggered at 11 34 pm local
time dr mackowitz immediately registered
the sudden change in surrounding
landscape despite the darkness and
attempted to check their location on his
phone gps which did not work the
building became visible at the top of
the rocky hill it reminded me of site 16
a little bit these huge concrete walls
built into the cliffside and the big
spotlights along the walls not wanting
to wake his wife mekowitz continued
driving for several minutes the building
stayed at a static position with the
angle and my speed i should have been
getting closer but it wasn't like it was
moving parallel though obviously it
wasn't with its spotlights panning over
the hillside
makowitz suddenly became aware of a
movement to the left of the vehicle per
testimony it was a dark blot out in the
desert angled in such a way that i could
see it for several seconds as we sped by
from everything around it it was
obviously a three-dimensional object but
since it reflected no light you couldn't
really tell a couple miles later i saw
it again but it was further out so i
could see it longer it was moving at a
constant speed not the intermittent gait
of something on legs but the smooth pace
of a wheeled object it was moving
parallel to the interstate at a much
lower speed and we shot by pretty
quickly i thought i was hallucinating
makawetz then reports that the object
reappeared ahead of them moving
perpendicular to the interstate it
crossed into their path and mekowitz
rapidly breaked to avoid colliding with
it waking his wife the object was no
longer present and his wife suggested
she drive i was tired and a little
terrified but something in me was
screaming not to get out of the [ __ ]
car they continued and the building
disappeared from view at 1209 am local
time signaling their exit from
scp-6819-1
instance 306
circumstances 1977 pontiac firebird
trans am driver was site director paul
lagoo no passengers u.s 120 in
pennsylvania
observations
scp-6819 triggered at 203 am local time
director lagu immediately noticed the
sudden disappearance of other vehicle
lights it was a pretty empty road but i
could still see taillights of people way
ahead of me and the headlights of
oncoming traffic one by one they just
winked out like candles getting snuffed
out and attempted to call a colleague on
his phone but could not get signal lagoo
was suddenly temporarily blinded by a
bright light a spotlight followed his
vehicle for a few seconds before
drifting away lagoo regained control of
the vehicle and looked up at the
building on his right between the barbed
wire the guard towers and the spotlights
it looked like a fortress believing he
had taken the wrong exit he made a
u-turn and began accelerating in the
opposite direction until the building
disappeared from sight
after only two to three minutes the
building appeared again ahead of lagoo
once again on his right however the
taillights of other vehicles were
visible ahead of him as well as the
honking of horns he registered the
lights were not moving the cars were all
stopped in the right lane causing him to
switch lanes to drive past them as he
drove past he slowed to take a note of
the traffic jam all the cars were jet
black and looked brand new all of them
had their hazards on and were honking at
each other i was wondering why the hell
none of them just switched to the other
lane until i drove past all of them were
empty must have been 30 or 40 cars
backed up and honking at each other with
their windows down and not a single
person inside any of them
ligue accelerated to 130 miles per hour
and exited scp-68
at 2 25 a.m local time
instance 398
circumstances 1999 honda crv driver was
agent alice sterling only passenger her
pet golden retriever us-95 in nevada
observations
scp-6819 triggered at 1 15 am local time
agent sterling does not immediately
notice but reports her dog immediately
began to behave strangely and restlessly
the building does not become visible for
several minutes but agent sterling notes
she began to hear a soft but
high-pitched buzzing i figured that what
was making kane nervous it sounded like
a snake rattle almost from outside the
vehicle her dog began to whine from the
back seat
sterling noticed a discoloration on the
road ahead and slowed her vehicle down
as she approached she noted a number of
black cars stopped in a row in the left
lane similar to instance 306 however all
the asphalt guard rails cars and nearby
rocks were coated in a greenish shifting
substance as sterling shifted to the
right lane and slowly drove by she was
able to inspect them closer cicadas
hundreds and thousands of them at the
very least they were everywhere buzzing
and screaming and making the air shimmer
i don't think cicadas ever come out this
far west not in these numbers my car
left a smashed trail of them and they
didn't even seem to care
the brood of cicadas continued for
almost a mile and a half during which
the building became visible much closer
than in previous instances it seemed
safe strong i didn't see any cicadas on
those walls despite the lights she also
noticed a unpaved road diverging from
the highway that led up the hill to the
building and moved to take it at this
point her dog began to loudly and
insistently bark and she missed her turn
sterling continued and exited scp-6819-1
at 1 38 am local time
instance 434
circumstances 2017 ford f-150 driver was
researcher samuel c barr no passengers
but sibar was transporting a whole hog
in the bed of the truck
us-123 in kentucky
observations
scp-6819 triggered at 12 56 a.m cebar
immediately noticed and unsuccessfully
attempted to establish a radio
connection with command then rapidly
accelerated in an attempt to exit
scp-6819
as fast as possible i figured that since
turning around doesn't work the fastest
way out is directly through the building
became visible within one to two minutes
due to the speed sibar was traveling at
uncharacteristically its spotlights were
all fixed on a singular point down the
road instead of wandering across the
area as usual as cbar approached the
point he noticed an obstruction in the
road and was forced to slow down
the twisted flaming wreckage of a black
suv was thrown across the road it was
gruesome i think it had crashed into the
guardrail but the car was totaled they'd
been thrown through the windshield jesus
[ __ ] christ illuminated by the
spotlights a number of small fires were
present throughout the crash scene as
well as a number of partially burned
bodies lying face down on the ground
seabard took the truck partially
off-road to avoid the crash one bloody
figure was lying several dozen meters
away from the spotlights and wreckage at
the end of a long trail of blood and
viscera as cebar returned to the road he
did not register this figure's presence
in the darkness and crushed them under
the wheels of the truck
the sudden jolt panicked sibar i thought
someone had jumped on the [ __ ] truck
i thought i was gonna die and he
accelerated to 110 miles per hour until
he exited scp-6819-1
at 109 am local time after establishing
a radio connection and reporting the
incident to command zebar stopped at a
gas station and noticed the raw hog in
the bed of the truck now had large
chunks torn out of its flesh
interview
interviewer dr seth sayner
subject agent barry novak
playing log now
hey barry sorry about the wait
it's fine
[Applause]
not exactly
a lot going on here
just for the record can you recount what
happened one more time
again
[Applause]
you don't have to go into too much
detail we just want it on tape
all right
i was driving down at 160 near cortes
it was like two in the morning
there were some other cars around but it
was mostly dead
when did you notice something had
changed
i have a little compass
on my dash
it started freaking out
then i noticed i couldn't see anything
it's a dark highway but
there weren't any tail lights headlights
i couldn't even see the moon
utter pitch blackness beyond my high
beams
and that wasn't even
i'm not afraid of the dark
never said you were
i was
as a kid
i always slept with a nightlight in the
corner of my room
made me feel safe
anyway
that's when i saw the building
can you describe it to me it was perched
on the cliff side
it was
imposing
these huge flying concrete walls
and the big card towers
it was bright too
the only source of light in the area
were those
huge spotlights and floodlights
and you kept driving
sure
at this point i knew where i was and
what to do so
i continued driving
okay
the spotlights followed me
it followed my car
i mean
do they always do that
it's not exactly common but we've seen
it happen
it scared me so i sped up
i was waiting to see what was
going to be in the road in the dark
you saw
figures
yeah
maybe four or five people
it's hard to remember
standing in the middle of the road
facing me
could you describe them
they were white
naked
masks
black masks covering their entire heads
they were holding things either guns or
or bats
it's hard to say
doing anything
just standing there
as you know the absence of living people
in
scp-689-1 is usually an important
signifier
are you sure they were people they
looked like people
i don't know if they were actually alive
or actually human
but they looked in
what did you do
i wasn't prepared for a fight
it's a shitty little prius
i can run someone over but if i smashed
in the window i was done for
i i saw the road
the road
the dirt path going off up the hill
to the building
and you followed this path
yeah i figured it was a better option
than playing chicken with some gunmen
can you describe to me the uphill drive
the road was bumpy but it was drivable
i switched into second gear and started
going up
then the headlights chomped through the
bush
then the spotlights fell on me
all of them
shining
down on the roof of the car
blinding me
you stopped the car
yeah yeah
then they wandered off me formed the
line
leading to one of the walls of the
fortress
shining on a big door
what kind of door
uh it looks like a the blast door i'm
almost
all affair looked like
a bunker how did you feel
weird
a blend of scared
and safe
[Applause]
safe
the light was
comforting and the walls looked very
safe
i started driving up to it
and you saw the door opening
yeah
just as the door started to open
everything went dark again you passed
out behind the wheel
the airbags were deployed when we found
you in a ditch by the highway like
this
they're probably going to pull the plug
sometime tomorrow
your family will be taken care of
i'm
i'm sorry barry
it's not your fault
i'm sure i've plowed through those
masked [ __ ]
killing people isn't natural instinct
that's the thing isn't it
you're driving through the dark
you see a bright light you assume safety
a nightlight yeah
it shows you're not alone
churning through the dark and calling
you closer
like an angler fish
i would like to give a special thank you
to
joss travolca oren pace
aletreon
zargara
professor puffer
retalias
jk
segnar
your local fishman
derivative
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
a real american hebrew
hms lily
the almighty fish
scio dio demnatus
eric corbige
longinus
the morrigan
carimel lashmui
james
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you